HIS BEHAVIOR.
IT'S FRUSTRATING, BUT I'M GLAD
THE TRUTH IS COMING OUT AND I'M
GLAD WERE TELLING OUR VIEWERS
ABOUT IT.
MR. BELL, THANK YOU.
HE SAYS HE WAS RECENTLY CALLED
IN FOR QUESTIONING BY SCHOOL
OFFICIALS FOR DARING TO GO TO A
GUN RANGE WITH HIS DAD.
KYLE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
AM I MISSTATING THAT?
TELL US WHAT YOU DID THAT EARNED
YOU A TRIP TO VISIT WITH ARMED
AUTHORITIES AT YOUR SCHOOL.
WHAT WAS YOUR CRIME?
>> IT WAS IN A TRIP, IT WAS AN
INTERROGATION.
IT WAS A CLEAR ATTEMPT TO
INTIMIDATE ME.
THEY USED VERY, VERY HARSH
INTIMIDATION TACTICS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, I WENT
SHOOTING WITH MY DAD AT A GUN
RANGE.
I DID EVERYTHING PEACEFULLY.
I WENT SHOOTING WITH MY DAD AND
I DID ABSOLUTELY NOTHING WRONG.
I PUT A VIDEO OF ME SHOWING MY
ADMIRATION FOR THE SECOND
AMENDMENT AND TELLING PEOPLE TO
EDUCATE THEMSELVES ABOUT THE
SECOND AMENDMENT BECAUSE WE
CAN'T TRUST OUR GOVERNMENT TO
DEFEND OURSELVES.
>> Tucker: SO YOU INTO A GUN
RANGE WITH YOUR DAD WHICH I
THINK IT IS STILL LEGAL IN THIS
COUNTRY.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THIS BECAUSE YOU LEARN
GUN SAFETY AND HOW TO HANDLE A
GUN APPROPRIATELY.
YOU DIDN'T MISUSE IT, YOU GOT
CALLED IN AND INTERROGATED.
WHAT QUESTIONS COULD THEY HAVE
ASKED YOU A QUESTION MARK WHAT
WOULD BE THE INTERROGATION?
>> SO I COME INTO THE OFFICE AND
IT WAS ALL VERY, VERY WEIRD.
I GET SAT DOWN AND THE POLICE
OFFICER SAYS KYLE, YOU'RE TAKING
PRIVATE AP CLASSES, WHY WOULD
YOU DO SOMETHING LIKE THIS?
I WAS IN SHOCK.
I SAID WHAT YOU MEAN?
HE SAID BYE WOULD YOU DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS?
THEY CAME IN THERE WITH THE
NOTION THAT I HAD DONE SOMETHING
WRONG BY GOING TO A GUN RANGE.
HE SAID YOU TWEETED OUT A VIDEO
OF YOU AT A RANGE.
AND I SAID DID YOU SEE THE
TWEET?
HE SAID NO, I DON'T DO TWITTER.
AND I SAID CHECK THE TWEET.
THE TWEET IN ITSELF IS A VIDEO
OF ME SHOOTING A FIREARM TELLING
PEOPLE TO EDUCATE THEMSELVES
ABOUT THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
THEN THE BROWARD SHERIFF'S
OFFICER COMES INTO THE ROOM.
HE SITS RIGHT BEHIND ME VERY,
VERY, VERY CLOSE AND THEN THE
INTERROGATION TRULY STARTED.
HE SAID WHO'S DONE IS IT, WHO
DID YOU SHOOT IT WITH?
IS IT YOUR DAD'S GUN?
WHEN DID YOU GO?
THIS ENTIRE TIME, I SAID DID I
DO ANYTHING WRONG QUESTION MIKE
THIS IS STILL AMERICA THE LAST
TIME I CHECKED, I CAN GO TO A
GUN RANGE AND SHOOT IT
PEACEFULLY.
THEY SAID DON'T GET SNAPPY WITH
ME.
AND I SAID OKAY, CAN I RECORD
THIS?
AND THEY SAID NO.
IN REALITY --
>> Tucker: THEY DIDN'T ALLOW
YOU TO RECORD THE CONVERSATION?
>> DON'T KNOW, I SPECIFICALLY
ASKED AND HE SAID NO.
>> Tucker: YOU WERE WITH HER
FATHER.
>> THEY TRIED TO TELL ME OR
INTIMIDATE ME TO SOMEHOW
INCRIMINATE MY FATHER.
IT WAS A REAL PUSH.
THEY CAME IN THERE SAYING I WAS
AT FAULT FOR EXERCISING MY
SECOND MOMENT RIGHT AT THE GUN
RANGE.
IT COMES DOWN TO THIS.
WHY SHOULD I BE INTERROGATED FOR
PEACEFULLY GOING TO A GUN RANGE?
I SAID WHY DO ANYTHING WRONG?
HE SAID NO, YOU'RE NOT A THREAT.
SO WHY ARE THEY CALLING ME DOWN?
IS EVERY SINGLE INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS GOING DOWN TO A GUN RANGE
GOING TO BE CALLED DOWN?
WHERE IS THE END?
IT'S A CLEAR ROAD TO TYRANNY.
>> Tucker: I SYMPATHIZE WITH
THEIR FATHER BECAUSE HE'S AN
ADULT AMERICAN CITIZEN.
HE CAN DO WHAT HE WANTS WITHIN
THE BOUNDS OF THE LAW WITHOUT
GETTING SECOND-GUESSED BY SOME
SCHOOL PERSON.
WHAT DID HE SAY ABOUT THIS?
>> MY DAD DOESN'T UNDERSTAND HOW
SOMETHING SO SMALL CAN TURN INTO
SOMETHING, WHY WAS MY SON BEING
INTERROGATED?
THE SCHOOL HAD AN EVEN CALLED MY
FATHER ABOUT THIS, THEY DIDN'T